merci oui en effet c'est clairement mon
meilleur résultat en carrière en gagnant
un tournoi aussi relevé après c'était
évidemment mon objectif
un jour ou l'autre de gagner ce type de
tournoi et je suis content d'avoir
débloqué le compteur
oui bien sûr c'était important et
également de ne pas perdre deux parties
et bien sûr toutes ces victoires et
surtout comme magnus évidemment ça
m'aide aussi à me projeter sur l'avenir
et à pouvoir jouer ma chance à fond
contre contre lui dans l'est dans les
prochains tournois j'étais je n'étais
pas certain d'être toujours en contrôle
j'avais évidemment une très bonne
position mais je n'étais pas forcément
satisfait de certaines de mes décisions
notamment dans l'ouverture mais après
j'ai réussi à me reprendre et vite et où
toutes ses chances pour obtenir du
compte le jeu et finalement l'emporter à
la barbe ce n'était pas spécialement mon
idée à la base mais après ça ça me
convient bien ça ne pose pas de souci et
et je suis content du résultat non
qu'après voilà
après j'ai toujours eu du mal à vraiment
faire très attention justement amont
civique à ce genre de détails décider si
un jamais vraiment prêté attention à ma
tenue et surtout à ma coiffure mais bon
voilà c'est juste comme ça c'est pour
changer